we don't know much about you Queen Idina
but we do know that you love your girls
more than anything all you ever wanted
was to protect Elsa and Anna and make
arendelle proud but unfortunately your
journey was cut short but don't take it
personally
Disney has a knack for taking parents
out of the picture prematurely we're
excited to see you pop up in frozen -
even though it'll only be in a flashback
frozen - is going to be epic but for the
most part Disney has managed to keep its
plot under wraps what we do know though
is that Queen I do know has a very
special part to play keep watching to
find out why Elsa isn't the only magical
person in her family Elsa frozen - is so
close we can almost taste it fans are
eager to find out what the sequel has in
store for their favorite Disney Princess
sisters the frozen do trailer is beyond
epic and promises a journey like no
other we see Elsa trying to cross the
vast wild ocean and on a leaping from
rock to rock and sheer determination
[Music]
we know for sure that the gang will
embark on a last-second dirty and travel
through the enchanted lands frozen to
will center around Queen Elsa and the
origins of her powers Elsa and Anna lost
their mom and dad when they were just
kids they had to grow up fast behind
closed doors and learn to rule over the
kingdom of arendelle overnight but if
there's one person onon Elsa's still go
to for comfort and advice it's their
mother Queen I do not although she may
no longer be alive she exists in their
memories Queen I Doudna is going to
heavily influence the events of frozen -
although she won't be there physically
will be shown a flashback of I Doudna
singing her girl's a lullaby in the song
she sings them is everything a snippet
from the brand-new musical number all's
found was presented to the d23 Expo
audience in this song I dunno sings
about where the wind meets the sea a
river full of memory and more while it's
meant to put her children to sleep it's
almost as if I dunno is hinting at
something big and that got us thinking
what a queen I dunno knows exactly where
Elsa's powers come from both I Doudna
and a ganar told grand pabbie that elsa
was born with her powers and not cursed
born with the powers of caste born and
they're getting stronger so they might
know more about Elsa's origins than we
think in frozen - Elsa will start
hearing a voice inside of her head and
it's going to drive her mad
luckily Anna will come to the rescue and
help soothe Elsa's worries by singing
their mother's lullaby the sisters will
fall asleep safe and sound
but later on Anna will wake up alone I
also follow someone's voice into the
unknown desperate for answers so what if
it's her mother's voice calling to her
obviously someone wants Elsa to find out
the truth about who she is so that makes
us wonder did I do Nicola by as a map
for Elsa just in case she wouldn't be
around to give her the answers if Elsa
was born with her powers there's a good
chance that one of her parents have
powers of their own
[Music]
and we think there's more to I do know
than meets the eye in the frozen -
trailer we see a sad little Elsa sitting
on the edge of her bed suddenly she
looks up optimistically as her mom gazes
out the window to the Northern Lights
from where we're standing it looks like
I dunno is having a moment with the
lights so could this be where Elsa's
powers come from and as I do to share
some of Elsa's abilities it sure looks
like it we know from the trailers at
Elsa and the gang are going to journey
north across the enchanted land and we
also know that they're going to cross
paths with lieutenant destin matias who
has been lost in the forest for a
handful of decades matias will give elsa
a history lesson on her family tree
starting with her grandfather whether or
not matthias is real as a mystery but
his memory sure is so is it possible
that idea and ignores essence still live
in the enchanted lands well it is an
enchanted forest after all do you have
to go you'll be fine Elsa although many
fans think that Anna will get powers in
frozen - we aren't entirely convinced
the mysterious pink flames from the
trailer might belong to Queen I Doudna
instead of Anna the pink flames and the
Northern Lights
share a similar colour and we think I do
know is connected to them in some way or
another Queen I do now has a very
important part to play in frozen -
everything about her lullaby stands out
and basically instructs Elsa on where to
go to find answers so clearly there's a
place where Elsa belongs we're guessing
that Agner wasn't magical in the
slightest after all he tried to teach
Elsa to conceal her powers and repress
her feelings instead of encouraging her
to master them I do know was a lot more
patient and understanding prompting us
to think that she's got magical
properties - someone is calling Elsa
from far away
they're beckoning her to embark on a
quest to find out the truth about her
heritage if else is hearing her mother's
voice it makes total sense as she would
desperately try to cross an ocean but
the real question is is I do news still
alive or is someone playing a cruel joke
on Elsa whatever the answer may be we
know that Queen I do news flashback will
derail the events of frozen -
we'll protect her she can learn to
control I'm sure so what do you guys
think as I do not have powers to sound
off in the comments give this video a
big thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe to the things
thank you for watching we'll see you
soon
[Music]